aaron rodgers you know this is a guy
whose legacy is on the line
one super bowl appearance in his career
it has felt incomplete
it has felt like a partial failure yes
he's got the one he's got the win he's
got the super bowl mvp
brett favre was never a super bowl mvp
but but
what does the future hold let's play a
little aaron rodgers from earlier this
week shedding some light
or not on where things go from here for
him
win or lose super bowl or not here's
aaron rodgers
i'm always just trying to stay present
especially this year as much as anything
and just
enjoy the moments and
i hope there's more opportunities but i
don't know i mean i really don't and
that's stuff to that in my control i
mean my future
uh is a beautiful mystery i think
you know it's become more of a beautiful
mystery now
than before before he was very resolute
he was very determined and
want to play past four do you want to
stay with the packers and i think the
jordan loved draft picking
i gave mark murphy some credit for doing
some high
level button pushing and lever
manipulation to get aaron rodgers into
this sweet spot that he's been in all
year where he is
focused on the present he is trying to
get the most out of this season he's not
thinking about the future
i i just i can't but look they didn't
just haphazardly draft
jordan love they did it because on one
hand they're trying to think about the
future but on the other hand to the
extent that it gooses aaron rodgers in
the present
so be it and it has in a positive way
you know we thought he was going to be
salty and angry and upset he found a way
to just kind of embrace where he is who
he is what he's doing
and i think that comes through i'm not
thinking about the future anymore i'm
thinking about right now
and maybe that's what you need to get
yourself to the point where you get back
to a super bowl and win another one
peter
and you know look i think when this
the story of this season in green bay is
written regardless of what happens
uh and i understand when everybody says
oh there's only one
team that really has a great season to
me the green bay packers getting back
to the nfc championship game back to the
final four again for the second straight
time
under matt lafleur this team being 28
and seven over the last 35 games when in
the last thr
the previous 35 games they were 15 19
and one
i mean this is a great accomplishment
this team
is on the right path whatever the score
of the game and the result
is on sunday and to me to emphasize that
mike
i think you have seen a more zen
aaron rodgers than you've ever seen in
your life
and and you know he's not he's not mad
at the world sometimes he doesn't like
kind of quietly lash out at his critics
okay and and the other day i talked to
brandon staley and i congratulated him
on getting
the job and and we went back and i
talked to him about what happened after
the game
he had 30 seconds on the field 20
seconds
on the field with aaron rodgers after
the game and
you know just talking about uh how you
know their futures together and
rogers thought he was going to be
playing them for a long time but now who
knows
and and the one thing that brandon
staley said
is he said that this guy is playing
quarterback at a perfect level
and look at how happy he is look at how
content he is
and it's just a totally different aaron
rodgers that's not going away
that will last into 21 and 22 and as
i've said mike
i believe that uh that the quarterback
jordan love who was drafted to be aaron
rodgers heir
will instead be aaron rodgers jimmy
garoppolo
you know that the packers will end up
trading jordan love
because look can you imagine aaron
rodgers
breaking down in two years i can't
and i i think he's got if he wants it
he's got several years left
he's about the same age when uh tom
brady saw jimmy garoppolo show up and
even though garoppolo was a second round
pick it had that same effect the
patriots hadn't hadn't won a super bowl
in
in 10 years and they won three
promptly after the arrival of garoppolo
and then garoppolo ends up in san
francisco so that may be exactly
what at some level it was calculated to
do for aaron rodgers because we have
seen a higher level from him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports